everyone I brought my thingamabob my
weapons great thingama Bob oh
Tsar that's your thing
[Music]
bend over and grab your ankles no a
couple days ago we talked about the new
Little Mermaid movie which is atrocious
and I haven't seen it but of course I
can say that you don't need to see it in
order in order to say that one of the
songs in that movie that went viral for
all the wrong reasons if you're Disney
uh because it's like potentially the
worst song ever made it's just it's just
terrible and so it was suggested to me
by McKenna that because I so hated
having to suffer through that song what
we should do today is play a bunch of
other terrible Disney songs so let's
just uh let's start with this this one
is from this one's from Moana Let's uh
watch a little bit of it
is
scrub the deck and make it look shiny I
will Sparkle like a wealthy woman's neck
just a sec don't you know Fisher dum dum
dum anything that did us
beginners
fish dinner I just love free food all
right yeah no it's not five turn it off
stop so here's the thing I saw Moana I
believe I've seen Moana I think I took I
probably I think I took my kids to see
it when it was I saw it in theaters with
my with my kids right sure and I
remember thinking that it's not terrible
I remember thinking that it's not a
remix that was my first thing going in
it's not a remake it's actually making
original content you know there's
nothing there's nothing woke in it and
it's like it's not it's not terrible
I don't remember this at all I must have
I must have blocked this from my memory
I must have suppressed this deep down in
the recesses of my memory because I have
no recollection of this awful song or I
don't know what's happening in this
scene
is she about to be eaten by this crab
thing that is pretty bad but it's not it
doesn't rise to the level of the The
Little Mermaid song so let's keep going
this one is from uh okay this is from
the new Pinocchio I guess let's listen
I'll design the perfect wooden shoe
and then we'll sing and dance the whole
day through if you get splinters hater
I'm your conscience Jiminy Cricket ah
that's in the wrong that's that's
competing for is that trying to be bad
is that the joke
and the other thing about the Pinocchio
remake is how many Pinocchio movies do
we actually need like this movie
there are so many versions of this and I
know this because recently I was trying
to uh
put Pinocchio on for my kids like the
original you know the the one from the
60s or the 50s or whenever they came out
and I was trying to put that on for my
kids and I so I type Pinocchio
there's like there's 15 versions of this
movie every year they come out with a
Pinocchio remake is it really the kind
of movie that it's like there's so much
in that story that you need to keep
retelling it over and over again I bet a
lot of you folks don't believe that do
you like the kids don't like Pinocchio
Pinocchio said you know
[Music]
Gilbert said that the children said that
kids don't like Pinocchio you know so I
think Pinocchio exists as the kind of
story and the kind of movie that kids
hate and it's this is not modern it's
like it's always been this way kids hate
it but then they become parents and
their perception of the story changes
and they try to force their kids to
watch it and the kids still don't care
so Pinocchio was never great but they
somehow made it worse with that song in
the not too distant past private
citizens used to be largely that if you
can imagine private what's changed well
the internet changed think about
everything you've ever searched for
watched or tweeted on the internet now
imagine all of that data being crawled
through collected and aggregated by
Third parties into permanent public
records to keep my data private when I
go online I use expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there whose
sole business involves buying and
selling your data they don't even have
to tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent either one of these
data points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your physical location
but you can mask your IP address with
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection through an encrypted server
that makes it more difficult for third
parties to find me if it sounds
complicated it's not because all you
have to do is just tap one button on the
app and then you're protected so if like
me you believe that your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated VPN on the market use MyLink
expressvpn.com Walsh YT to get three
extra months free that's exp
rssvpn.com Walsh YT clip three is uh I
don't know what this is Diane Guerrero
Encanto
which one is that is that a Pixar thing
oh is that the Mexican one that's the
Mexican one okay
go ahead
[Music]
yeah it sounds like that sounds like a
pop song it sounds like a modern pop
song and I mean that in the worst
possible way I don't mean that as a
compliment it just sounds like the kind
of just just like
it's not aggressively obnoxious I don't
think it doesn't it doesn't make your uh
it doesn't it doesn't make you nauseous
listening to it it's not good either
it's just nothing but there's no charm
to it that's the other thing you know
the old Disney movies those songs you
still remember those songs because they
had there's a certain kind of charm to
them and all this stuff when they make
these remakes and the new Disney movies
they're not able to capture that
charm and that enchantment anymore they
don't they don't have it because all of
these movies are made by they're not
made by storytellers okay they're made
by committee they're made by like it's
like these are corporate products and
they're made by marketing departments
and they sit around in rooms and
meetings and they come up with these
stories uh based on you know what's
going to make those money and how can
they merchandise it and how they can
they sell things that's all that matters
so there's no there's no magic to it
okay mechantho is not the Mexican one so
it was deeply racist to my part yeah
Wild
segment's gone great let's listen to
this one
[Music]
even
even she will still torment me calm me
hurt me move
become what may
[Music]
Waiting by an Open Door okay yeah I
could tell that's new I could tell
that's new
it it sounds like it's their impression
of the kind of a Disney song they're
doing a it's like they're doing it's a
parody it's a parody of a 90s Disney
song but but it can't actually capture
the essence
and it also looks so stupid you take the
Beast and you try to make it realistic
let's make it gritty and realistic you
have this humanoid Buffalo creature it's
making realistic uh and it looks
ridiculous and I'm not going to get into
the whole thing about Beauty and the
Beast we've already talked about it all
my problems my many problems with the
story to begin with you know and the
fact that Gaston is the real good guy in
the story we've talked about that but
she goes
she gets kidnapped by and by a beast
like an animal it's not even a human
and falls in love with it remember she
falls in love with that thing before she
doesn't even know wait a second does she
know
does she know that he used to be a human
I don't think she knows that so it's not
even like she she's she's falls in love
with the potential or she knows that he
used to be a human and if she yeah she
thinks that he's literally just like a
buffalo creature a talking Buffalo
and she falls in love with with him
Disney's been woke for a while because
they're promoting bestiality even all
the way back in the 90s all right um I
guess we should finish this up should we
finish this up by watching that uh
Little Mermaid song again listening to
it probably not but let's do it anyway
[Music]
well I was flying over land and seeing
ear to the ground then I came flying
here for you to see and hear what I
found remember that's why I remember
myself yeah we didn't need to do that we
didn't need to do that uh nothing comes
close to that when you listen to that
again you realize that it's just that
exists on a tear that none of these
others saw other songs are bad they're
just bad they're bad so there are a lot
of bad songs are dime a dozen you hear
those all the time
that though transcends Badness it
reaches some other it's it's almost it's
impressive it is actually I'm almost
impressed by it a strange new respect
that you could make a song that terrible
good I think this is productive and uh
and I think it's stuff okay we've heard
enough all right
good